only when your attention and involvement
is indiscriminate
does the universe open up to you if you
can communicate and connect not just
communicate
it takes you and literally gives you and
i a decided edge over others finite
players play to be bet to beat the
people around them
infinite players play
to be better than themselves
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn 10 of the
best habits that you can have in your
life
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one self-regulate with joe dispenza when
you're feeling gratitude and your heart
is open you're broadcasting energy into
the field the frequency the frequency
you lay the intent of the thought of
your health or your wealth
that frequency can carry the thought of
your wealth it can carry the thought of
your health if you're suffering
you can't the suffering does not carry
that energy does not carry the thought
of your wealth it carries a different
set of thoughts so then so then we're
teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated and you
better know how to self-regulate and you
have to know
the moment you disconnect from the
energy of your future because of some
circumstance in your life and you lose
that feeling
if you're practicing it on a daily basis
with your eyes closed then the next
level is to be able to open your eyes
and do it right in the moment and be
able to self-regulate and change
the the frustration from some experience
in your life back to the energy of your
future now
that requires great awareness and great
effort but if you have a community of
people
that are practicing this on a daily
basis
and they're connected to their future
because that's where their their mind is
they begin to want the future
more than the emotions of the past so
we've done enough measurements now lewis
to know that we can teach people how to
do that and we have evidence that people
can sustain it
for 45 minutes to an hour it's a skill
now they know that they know how to do
it so now they have brain coherence and
heart coherence well once the heart
begins to become orderly and coherent it
acts as an amplifier and it drives
energy to the brain so now the brain is
getting more energy once the heart is
open and then you're thinking different
set of thoughts and those thoughts
produce different chemicals for you to
feel more of that and here comes
nitric oxide from oxytocin and then all
of a sudden your heart literally starts
to swell it literally begins to open up
and there's more energy going there and
now you're coming from a different level
of mind habit number two have an
indiscriminate attention with sad guru
in your book you talk about something i
thought was so interesting to set the
faucet to a certain drip rate and do
nothing but focus on the dripping of the
faucet for like seven minutes or
something the idea is to pay attention
to something which has no relevance to
you
see people are
have divided the universe
this is important this is not important
this person is important for me this
person is not important this is
important for me that's not important
for me you divided the universe you will
never know anything this way
indiscriminate focus indiscriminate
attention
i am not attending to you because you
are somebody with a cobra in your heart
all right
it doesn't matter who i speak to who i
am with i'm the same way
indiscriminate
only when your attention and involvement
is indiscriminate
does the universe open up to you
you have discriminated
naturally you close you know people come
to me and say sadhguru i want to walk
the spiritual path
i say okay
be here for three days
let's see what we can do so no such root
day after tomorrow my uncle's daughter's
birthday i have to go
oh you want to get enlightened
and day after tomorrow uncle's
daughter's birthday also all right
we got one and a half days
you do one thing you do this this and
this they say sakura but i don't like
this
all right i'll give them a small piece
of paper
and say okay write down things that you
like will do only do that
you won't believe it in this entire
universe most people like only three or
four things
when
you're so constipated in your head
that you lack only three or four people
or three or four things in your life
how do you want to open up to the
existence
because life is happening because of its
openness
this is a fundamental difference between
death and life is
people are thinking it's just breath all
right on one level that is also openness
whether you allow this to happen or you
don't allow it to happen
whether you did it consciously or
unconsciously but it's happening isn't
it openness is on every subatomic
particle is in communication with
everything that's why this is going on
breath is happening so much is happening
in connection with everything it is only
in openness you're alive
as you close doors
you're dying in installments
dying in installments is torture
see
life is fantastic if you're alive and
fully alive
if you're dead it's good
at least the neighbors may think so
[Music]
this may sound very
not so compassionate but i'm saying
everybody dies you and me will die all
right
if you're dead if the game is over
but if you're half dead oh
this is endless torture to yourself
when you are being tortured of course
you will share it with everybody else
habit number three be honest with tom
bilyeu just being honest even when it
sucks because let me tell you how many
times it's going to be where if you just
lied
oh god it would be so much easier and
you would probably get away with it and
but it the way that i explain lying to
people is you get away with it 50 of the
time and so it tempts you to think it's
a good strategy
but the other 50 of the time it is
cratering trust
and once you can't trust the person all
hope is lost
and there's nothing more beautiful than
being in a relationship with somebody
who makes you feel like they're your
number they're number one
and that you totally trust them and lisa
wrote this um instagram post about how
she could see a photo of me with my arm
around a woman or resting my head on a
villain or hugging her or whatever and
she it wouldn't even make her radar to
question it
so
that's the fun for us is having that
level of trust now it's like um i think
it's buffett that said you spend your
entire life building your reputation
only takes five seconds to lose it so
it's like we're so careful we for 18
years we've been earning trust with each
other so like dude so especially when i
was back at quest and
it was women would come and flirt and
hit on me because they wanted something
wanted to be sponsored by the company or
whatever and i was around bikini literal
bikini models like all the time
and so if ever there was going to be a
moment of insecurity for my wife it
would have been that period a she wasn't
insecure and b i the thought of throwing
away 18 years of shared experience of
all that trust and everything it's sex
is like rad and super exciting and i
love it the most but like compared to
what i would have to give up for
something like that it just doesn't rate
on the radar so
and by the way thing something like i'm
saying now which most people would hide
from their spouse oh that yeah of course
i find other people attracted what are
you talking about like we just openly
talk about that like she'll nudge me and
be like oh my god don't you think she's
hot
it's like that's just
we set up early on in the relationship
to be aggressively ourselves and one
thing that we both were really honest
about was i was like look it is human
nature you are going to find other guys
attractive and i will actually trust you
more if you
admit when you find somebody attractive
than if you say something stupid like i
only have eyes for you oh really you're
the only human in all of history to like
uh you know transcend their human nature
like it doesn't make sense yeah and then
that's a super fragile place to be
because what happens if i get older what
happens if i get injured or scarred like
then i'm really supposed to believe that
suddenly you're more attracted to
somebody with a scar than somebody
without like it doesn't make sense so we
all live in this fragile bubble of well
as long as they lie to me it's okay and
as long as i'm willing to believe and
even though secretly i know it's a lie
and then it's the more pious than now
like oh my god she's thinking all these
nice things about me but i'm actually
finding other people attractive and i'm
just lying about it and so then you're
like wait if i'm lying about it is she
lying about it and so it just it erodes
all that trust so from the jump we were
like look you're going to find other
people attractive i'm going to find
other people attractive but let me
introduce you to this magical word
called commitment
now i'm with you because i love you
because i respect you
but i'm also with you because i'm
committed to you and so you don't have
to worry that i'm going to be looking
over my shoulder for a more attractive
woman there are going to be more
attractive women than you for sure
especially as you age
who
cares you're my wife
we have shared an experience we've
shared a life we've built this around
each other and commitment means
something to me going back to having
that code that you live by
and the rules and the code that i live
by i'm never going to betray that yeah
so it's like
we've always said i may break up with
you one day because i'm not saying that
like oh there's nothing you could do
that would make me break up with you for
sure there is but i'm never gonna cheat
on you
i may come and say i'm breaking up with
you because i'm going to go have sex
with somebody else but i'm absolutely
not going to go have sex with somebody
behind your back never going to happen
so like having that trust and knowing
who the other person is like all that
stuff is is super meaningful and look
there's just more and more and more
stuff but those are some big ones what's
up everybody i want to talk about the
amazing book by evan carmichael built to
serve i want to read you guys a section
this is from um a part under the heading
of your pain is your strength
this is the fundamental mind shift that
most people never make but is required
for success the pain that you went
through that you're trying to forget
it's your strength it's the way through
it's your answer that pain is how you
become the tree you've experienced the
pain grow from it and are stronger now
and are able to help others who need the
support
so there it is your pain is the very
thing that's going to get you through
it's kind of like what ryan holliday
says the obstacle is the way all right
guys check it out build to serve by evan
carmichael who could teach a master
class on how to be a badass and be good
to people dude is rad check out his book
a lot of amazing stuff in there habit
number four do the right things with
steve jobs somebody taught me a long
time ago a very valuable lesson which is
if you
do the right things on the top line the
bottom line will follow and what they
meant by that was if you get the right
strategy if you have the right people
and if you have the right culture
culture at your company you'll do the
right products you'll do the right
marketing you'll do the right things
logistically in manufacturing and
distribution and if you do all those
things right
the bottom line will follow habit number
five outdo yourself with simon sinek i
spoke at an education summit for
microsoft i also spoke at an education
summit for
apple
at the education for mike at the
education summit for microsoft i would
say that 70 of the executives spent
about 70 percent of their presentations
talking about how to beat apple
at the apple education summit a hundred
percent of the executives spent a
hundred percent of their
presentations talking about how to help
teachers teach and how to help students
learn
one is playing this way and one is
playing that way
one is playing finite
and the other one is playing infinite
gets which one gets frustrated
so at the end of my talk at microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
zune when it was a thing
and let me tell you
this thing was spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology i'd ever used the user
interface was incredible the design was
spectacular i absolutely loved it it was
easy to use and it was bright and
gorgeous and fanta it didn't work on
itunes which is a different problem so i
couldn't use it but but it was amazing
and elegant my god it was elegant
so i'm sitting in the back of a taxi
with a very senior apple executive sort
of employing number 12 kind of guy and
you know i like to stir pots so i turned
him i said you know
microsoft gave me their new zoom
and it is so much better
than your ipod touch
and he turned to me and he said
i have no doubt
conversation over
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your head and sometimes you're
behind
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it's worse
the goal isn't to be the best every day
the goal isn't to out to out do your
competition every day that's a finite
construction if i had said to microsoft
i've got the new ipod touch and it's so
much better than your zoom they would
have said can we see it what does it do
react react react react
finite players play to be bet to beat
the people around them
infinite players play
to be better than themselves
to wake up every single day and say how
can we make our company a better version
of itself today than it was yesterday
how can we create a product
this week that's better than the product
we created last week we also have to
play the infinite game it's not about
being ranked number one it's not about
having more followers on twitter than
your friends
it's not about outdoing anyone it's
about how to outdo
yourself
it's not about selling more books or
getting more ted views than somebody
else it's about how to make sure that
the work that you're producing is better
than the work you produced
before
you are your competition
and that is what ensures you stay in the
game the longest and that is what
ensures you find joy
because the joy comes
not from comparison
but from advancement habit number six
praise yourself with marissa peer praise
yourself there is nothing
nothing
nothing
that will build your self-esteem like
praise but your praises if you have
a shoppers and so you look really great
in the outfit yeah it suits you you must
buy it they have an agenda if your boss
says you're amazing at your job but i
need to give you work to do over the
weekend they have an agenda
someone dating you might have an agenda
and your mind knows that when when you
say
i'm great at my job i'm smart i'm kind
i'm nice people like me
there is no agenda unfortunately when
you go i'm rubbish at my job i'm boring
i always mess up and i have no friends
your mind lets that into because your
mind doesn't really care if what you say
is right or wrong
good or bad healthy or unhealthy let me
prove that to you
i want you to put your hand in front of
your face like that i want you to close
your eyes i want you to imagine
you have a big fat juicy lemon and i
want you to
breathe in that wonderful lemon smell
and just squeeze it a bit and feel that
wonderful lemon texture because nothing
quite smells like a lemon so still
really believing you have half a lemon
in your hand
open your mouth
shove that lemon in there cram that half
a lemon into your mouth and start
chewing
and sucking and biting and swallowing
the flesh keep sucking all that lemon
flesh into your mouth bite it chew it
suck out the juice
and you will notice what is happening is
your body is responding to a thought as
if it's a fact
your body is responding to the image and
thought of eating a lemon as if you are
actually eating a lemon and it's making
a saliva because thoughts are things
and every thought you have
has a physical reaction in your body and
an emotional response to when you think
i don't have friends i can't talk to
people i can't take things back to a
store
i can't ask for special treatment
i don't know how to talk to people then
your mind accepts that as a fact just
like the lemon but when you say
oh i can talk to anyone i'm an
interesting person i'm warm and friendly
people like me and i can make eye
contact i'm good at my job i can ask
someone out on a date i can tell the
person i'm involved with what i need
your mind accepts that too and someone
recently said they keep a lemon on their
desk now and look at it every day i'm
sure they change it every month because
that lemon reminds them every day that
they are responsible
for what they think and feel and you
know responsibility that word means an
ability to respond
so i want you to start to praise
yourself i want you to wake up in the
morning the first thing you go is i like
myself habit number seven master your
inner self with robin sharma you might
have a great mindset positive thinking
but if you have a heart set full of
anger if your emotional life is sad if
you're disappointed from the past if you
haven't done that the sweat lodges and
the journaling and the body work and the
affirmations to really open up a heart
set then you can have
the mindset of the elon musk you have
the mindset of a steve jobs you can have
a mindset of a kobe but you're going to
sabotage yourself from world class and
to me this is the great myth of positive
thinking you see a lot of people they
read all the books they're positive
thinkers they've got the vision boards
nothing changes why
because subconsciously
there's this wounding
and a lack of deservability
and it's unconscious and so they haven't
done the work or you may have not done
the work to make the
wounds of underservability and scarcity
and the low self-worth that's why
positive thinking alone does not work
this is to me a revolutionary insight
and by the way a lot of the people who
teach positive thinking in the past
are men so it's very male mind
and a lot of the people who are pioneers
of heart set
are women
heart
empathy
healing
and so
self mastery to me
and this is a pioneering model that i
teach
at personal mastery academy it's not
just mindset that's only 25 of self
mastery and as you know self mastery is
the dna of outer mastery you're never
going to perform higher than what's
going on within
mindset is only 25
heart set
your emotional life
working from confidence and love
and service
and that sense of internal freedom is
only another 25 so those two are only 50
percent there's a third interior empire
you want to get to world class which is
health set
working on your energy your nutrition
your daily exercise hacking your
longevity eating the right supplements
getting a massage every two weeks you
know my two massage protocol
doing your 60 minute nature walk every
week so that your
health set is at world class but that's
only 75 percent of the equation towards
self mastery you have a great mindset
great heart set great health set but if
you haven't worked on your soul set
turning down your ego you know you know
what disease and what energy depletion
is caused by your ego beating you
relentlessly about you not being enough
and seeing your industry peers
succeeding and you feel insecure and
irritated and angry and jealous well
where do you do that work within your
soul set the fourth interior
empire and as you do that you turn down
the ego and you open up your humanity
and you open up your spiritual life and
you become more soulful and then you
release work that is artistry versus
just to win in the next few months when
you literally give your life over to a
mighty mission that is larger than your
ego and you literally start to see your
work as a ministry for the benefit of
humanity and if you literally if you're
an artist or an entrepreneur or ceo
manager a coder a doctor a fighter
firefighter but literally if you saw
your work as your poetry and your
artistry and you were on a mighty
mission that was larger than even your
your ego
and yourself
what would the caliber of your output be
happen number eight connect and
communicate with john maxwell i think
the ability to connect and communicate
the number one criteria for success with
your family
with your marriage with your children
with your friends
in the workplace the marketplace in the
community
if you have the ability to connect with
people if you can communicate and
connect not just communicate
it takes you and literally gives you and
i a decided edge over others in the
advancement of what we're trying to
accomplish for example
in your notes presidential historian
robert dalek says that the success that
successful presidents exhibit five
skills and qualities that enable them to
achieve things that others don't
so he's talking about leaders and
presidents and people what makes some
achieve better than others here's the
five things they do well number one is
vision
number two pragmatism
number three
consensus building
the ability to put together a team and
get consensus
number four charisma
and number five
trustworthiness
being a trustworthy kind of a person
now what is interesting about these five
uh
these five things that set the better
presidents apart from maybe the average
ones four of the five
deal with connecting
vision is a definitely a connecting
skill the ability to to cast a future
vision consensus building getting people
to work together you have to be able to
connect to do that charisma of course
that's why people follow the quote the
pied piper and trustworthy four of the
five
of the skills needed to be successful as
a leader had a lot to do with connecting
so let me define connecting because
that's what this book is all about
connecting is the ability
to identify with people
and relate to them in such a way that it
increases our influence with them
in other words we can identify with them
until they say
he or she understands exactly what i
know and what i'm going through and we
can relate with them until we because of
that ability we begin to increase our
influence with them and of course what
do i teach about leadership very simple
leadership is influence habit number
nine always keep learning with mark
cuban if you're going to be
great at something you've got to make
the effort to be great at something um
whether it's sports whether it's physics
math science business whatever it may be
you know it's not just a natural skill
you've got you've got to to learn and
particularly if you're in the technology
industry because it changes every day
you know
when i got started and and you know
after i got i i got it i was a bartender
when i first came to dallas got into the
pc industry got fired started my own
company but
there i learned early on that there was
always something new and most people
didn't put in the time to learn it it's
like now with artificial intelligence
lots of people talk about artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
machine learning and neural networks not
a lot of people are putting in the time
to take classes or do the tutorials or
to to learn how to apply it to business
and that's what it takes and and you
know that's just something i've always
enjoyed so that i've been fortunate now
wait a minute are you doing that with ai
right absolutely what are you doing oh i
mean i've been on amazon doing the
machine learning tutorials right now i'm
going through um i've taken python
online classes really yeah absolutely um
if you go in my bathroom there's a
machine learning for dummies book
um i just started uh javascript neural
networks um there's a little tutorial
where they've got most of the library
brain.js and all the libraries and it's
not if you have a background in
programming it's not hard but i'm not
trying to be great at that but i want to
understand it so i understand all the
you know so i the nuanced elements of it
and how it works so that i have an
advantage inhabit number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
always think for yourself with michael
saylor the number one thing i got from
mit was confidence and the ability to
think for myself
that's the number one thing uh my my
first serious formative memory of mit is
i walk into a material science class
there's 350 people in the lecture hall
the professor walks out and he is a
consultant for nasa
and he's the top of his profession and
he designed these tiles that went on the
space shuttle
and he takes one of the tiles and it's
burnt it's got streaks on he holds up
from the class he says you know on the
space shuttle's last re-entry this tile
burned off the space shuttle
nobody at nasa knows why and we're not
sure how to fix it what do you think
okay and this is this is the first class
the first week freshman year we're all
18 year olds and it's a bunch of people
that are like the class valedictorian
from their various schools
and everybody looks at everybody and
there's a pregnant pause for 60 seconds
and you could see what's going on in
people's minds because first they're
like oh my god is there a reading i
missed is and the second thought is
wait a minute the answer to this
question is not in the back of the book
and the third you know and then at some
point someone raised it in and says you
know well maybe we should reverse the
composite lattices or or change the
material to something
and everybody goes oh my god that must
be the most br the bravest student in
the world
and it dawns on all of us that this
professor who's the smartest in the
world at what he does working for the
leading space agency in the world
doesn't have an answer to a fundamental
problem has never been answered in the
history of the human race he's looking
at a bunch of people he expects you to
think for yourself and figure it out and
he thinks maybe you can
and that idea that
you can actually uh
solve a problem for the first time in
human history
and you're expected to do it and they're
going to t they're going to give you all
the basic tools
the math the engineering disciplines the
scientific method to do it
i think that's enormously confidence
building at the end of the day because
the number one thing you want to learn
from your education is how to think how
to think right how to solve problems
after that
everything else is useful it's good it
was good to have contacts it was good to
have
to have the social interaction of other
intense thinkers and yes i think that's
probably the second most valuable thing
i got at mit
but you know
i will say that
you know in the 10 years after i left
mit i worked 3 500 hours a year 70 hours
a week 50 weeks a year dealing with
problems never before encountered
and i didn't think it was particularly
difficult because it was so difficult
getting through those four years at mit
where i was working 80 to 90 hours a
week
intellectually
butting heads with the smartest
professors the smartest students and
trying to solve
fundamental problems
i kind of felt like it hardened me
intellectually to cope
in the real world and so i i appreciate
the fact that they gave me that kind of
tough love
you know they didn't give us a textbook
with 37 questions with the answers in
the back of the book and let us memorize
the answers take the test
you know and give us a 95
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and just get
motivated you have a 35 chance of
actually following through that's what
the science says and that is not good
enough believe nation we need to do
better when you actually get motivated
and then create a specific plan of
action for what you're going to do this
week you have a 91 chance of following
through and when you publicly commit to
somebody else like leaving a comment
below on this video it jumps even higher
so i want that for you i want to know
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action for the
next week so i can celebrate with you
your chances of success go up in direct
proportion to your ability to one pick
the right things to work on and then two
focus on executing those things it's so
easy as an entrepreneur to get
distracted we love shiny objects right
we love dreaming up new ideas and
chasing these different projects but if
you look at a typical entrepreneur
you'll see that so many of their
projects start and stop and start and
stop and you take something ten percent
through or fifty percent through or
sometimes even like eighty percent
through but unless you're willing to
take it to a hundred you're not gonna
get the results you're not gonna get the
fruit of your labor because you're just
planting a whole bunch of seeds
constantly but you're never taking care
of that seed you're never watering it
right if you want to grow a plant you
got to plant the seed you got to care
for the soil you got to add nutrients
you got to water it daily it's got to
have enough sunshine you got to look
after that seed where most entrepreneurs
they don't they're starting to stop and
starting to stop and starting stopping
and you never actually get to where you
want to go people talk about
diversification you need to diversify
you need to diversify and while that's
really great as an investment strategy
if you don't know what you're invested
into it's good to have a big portfolio
of different things so that if one thing
doesn't do well something else is doing
well but it really sucks as business
advice because if you're trying to do 10
different things at once they're all
going to be mediocre they're all going
to be below average because you're going
up against people who are doing that
full-time and have their focus on it and
so it's much better as an entrepreneur
to one pick the things that you want to
focus on right and then two actually
focus on it do that work andrew carnegie
was once the richest person in the world
and he had a great quote saying how he
likes to put all of his eggs in one
basket and then you watch that basket
carefully
right it's only a major risk if you're
not watching the basket if you if you
take your eye off the ball you start
looking elsewhere and then something
happens to your industry
right and so being the expert
being the best at what you do
will always yield more results more
value more money to you than being okay
at 20 different things
be the best at one thing
focus no one had
the guidebook for 2020 up their sleeve
or no one could even have expected
themselves to be ready for this like no
matter how good you are at predicting or
trends or whatever it is
99 of people did not see this coming and
so there needs to be a bit of
self-compassion and not judging
ourselves it's so easy to get into that
spiral of one of the pieces of
negativity
is judgment of self like judging
ourselves for not being the best parents
not being the best partners not being
the best people and that's not a get out
of jail free card to behave how you want
what that is
genuinely allowing yourself to say hey i
need a bit of time just to adapt and be
compassionate because
no one had the mindset or the plan no
this is a black swan event
like yeah this is this is crazy and so
it's so extreme
but what should happen
and we were talking about this earlier
brendan is that in this moment you now
shift to go
okay i get it i'm going to build the
muscles that are going to help me build
adaptability and resilience for this
forever so i'm never going to be
blindsided again or i never want to be
in a situation again where i don't have
the tools so when you're thinking like a
monk for this situation and the
negativity the first thing that a monk
does is it's about putting on your own
protective shield
a lot of us walk out onto the
battlefield of life without having done
our own training and our own uh
shielding and our own protection
and so one of the ways or a very simple
practical way you can transform your
environment is a 3s model that i give in
the book and it cites scents and sounds
now sight sense and sounds have a huge
impact on your personal shield and the
strength of your shield and so when we
look at sight sights is what you see so
the big question i'd ask brendan anyone
who's listening or watching right now
is what's the first thing you see in the
morning
if it's your phone and studies show that
80 of people see their phone before
their partner in the morning and the
evening brendan right can you imagine
yeah the phone is the last thing you see
in the first thing you see in the
morning when you wake up when you do
that i would be awful
i was awful too i mean i you know this
is the point that you can't
put yourself in a uh you know something
often says like you know monks are not
training in a strip club like you don't
put yourself in the the complete extreme
opportunity sorry for my crudeness but i
love it i love it
you're not putting yourself in an
environment where you're set up to lose
when you're training
right when you're strong you can put
yourself in extreme environments but
when you're
you make it you make it yourself work so
if you're waking up in the morning
make the first thing you see be a quote
you love
make it be a work of art that inspires
you maybe a picture of your family that
really means something to you but make
it the first thing you see it could be
on your bedside table it could be at
your ceiling wherever it is that you
look first make it something that makes
you pause
because otherwise when you dive into
your phone you're now reacting to
everyone's agenda everyone's focused the
news the negativity and you're now
starting your day with people filling
you up rather than you being an abundant
creator
love that and so the first thing i say
is sight the second thing i'd say is
you've got to change your sounds in your
life and as monks
sound design was huge
so i discovered this when i lived in new
york city for two years and i used to
find myself feeling quite mentally tired
and i was always wondering what it was
and so i started researching and reading
as we do and i read about this thing
called cognitive load and it was saying
that when you're processing
insignificant irrelevant sound
your brain is trying to process
something that doesn't actually have
meaning or use and so now you're wasting
80 of your brain's energy on cognitive
load so examples are having the news on
in the background
examples are being around culture where
there's a lot of noise and gossip
drilling construction work all of that
creates cognitive load now sound how can
you change it
we all know brendan and you do this at
your seminars beautifully you put on
music and everyone's jumping up and down
and sound has that energy
to change our physiology and has that
chance sound as the opportunity to
change our biology and so for me
what sound are you playing in your work
environment is it the sound you want
intentionally what's the sound that you
wake up to by the way why does anyone
wake up to an alarm
right
none of us want to wake up to a fire
alarm so change the sounds that you work
to that you cook too that you sleep to
and you see your anxiety just
depreciate and the third one is uh sense
i think scents are so underestimated
when you smell a food you love you're
already tasting it you're feeling it
you're feeling the benefit of it there's
a reason why when we walk into a massage
room and i remember when we were in
puerto rico we went for one of those
beautiful which you recommended to me
that i couldn't miss it it was one of
those treetop massages yeah
beautiful place and so i went for one of
those it's amazing but massage parlors
or spaces or whatever
spas or whatever they're called
they all have scents like lavender
eucalyptus sandalwood this isn't just
like to make you feel good for two
seconds when you breathe and inhale that
it reduces your
reaction the desire for negativity it
brings that positivity into your life so
if you're creating these habits in your
day
you'll find that the external negativity
is still there it's not changing it but
it's able to less penetrate your shield
young students today
um
don't have those abilities to sit down
with you know i always say sit down with
your grandpa
maybe he wasn't ceo or something but
listen to
her stories his stories whatever because
there's a wealth of
information in there they overcame they
were through some tough times some
generations that they have done some
things and
i always find it fascinating when i can
find someone who's older than me and
wants to talk to i'll just sit there and
listen to when i just and you never know
somebody says where do you get your
ideas
i said by listening to people you know
people will say things and they don't
even understand what they said but i'm
the type of individual i'm a great
listener i can hear
and i've made a fortune of just
listening to people many of you
as i have been as i am are where you are
in your life based upon what you believe
and it's not just what you think you
believe on the surface it's also your
shadow beliefs that are holding you back
from moving into the life that you
believe
you deserve what i know is if you're not
looking at the shadows if you're not
looking at what is subconsciously
running through the tape in your mind
telling yourself you're not good enough
you're not worthy enough you're not
smart enough you're not enough
which is a tape that's playing for a lot
of people
if you're not conscious of that
then you end up acting out of that
belief system and not out of what you
know to be the truest or want to be the
truest for yourself but you don't become
what you want because so much of wanting
is about
living in the space of what you don't
have that's why jim carrey's story is so
powerful because he started to act as
though he already had it he would go up
to mulholland drive he would drive away
saying thinking i already have those
things i just haven't accessed them as
yet i believe those things are going to
come to me and i'm going to act like
they are so i'm going to move forward in
my life in order to
draw that to myself in such a way that
my actions are in alignment with what i
say
i believe
so if you start to think about that
really why are you where you are in your
life the choices that you have made
have been because of what you believe to
be true for yourself i'm going to tell
you the story of how i get to the best
definition of boundaries from a creative
kelly ray roberts
artist
portland
she's an artist who self-trained she was
an oncological social worker
like being a social worker in oncology
hard work she taught herself to paint
now she has a thriving huge business
and she was teaching art classes and
people were copying her art
and selling it
and selling it on etsy and selling it
different places
and one day she wrote a blog post and it
was about boundaries and she said let me
tell you what's okay and what's not okay
and she made a list of everything that
was okay
it's okay if you copy my art and hang it
in your house
it's okay if you download one of my
paintings and use it as a little sticker
on your website as long as it's
attributed it's okay if you do this it's
okay if in good spirit you do this and
this
it is not okay if you do the following
five things
i love it and it was the most
the clearest example and i called her
i'm like you just pulled some social
work magical on air and she goes yes it
would be so helpful if creatives were
all social workers because we're trained
and here's what's okay and what's not
okay you can come to my party love to
have you you can't get shit-faced yeah
you know and that's a hard conversation
so i think one of the reasons why or for
creatives the biggest thing i run into
and i work with creatives all the time
and interviewed them just almost
exclusively for rising strong um
is
people are afraid to put value on their
work
that's so true people are afraid to
charge for it people are afraid to
hey look i know you're a really good
photographer can you come and shoot this
wedding
for yeah for nothing for zero dollars
yeah for just like a free quiche
and you know whatever you're serving
no because you do you know how stressful
it is when you get do you know what
happens when you get to a wedding things
don't go well
i've never shot a wedding in my life
because the concept of the mother of the
bride is
way more frightening to me than
google
like head of advertising with you it's
like for the people who do that that is
that's a stressful line of work right
and so the answer is i'd love to shoot
the wedding
um
this is my fee for doing that
oh man come on this i mean i'd really
love to but you know because if you
don't put value on your work no one else
will i mean i can tell you this and i'd
be curious if this was your experience
what are the best ways for youth to get
started now in securing their financial
future
uh for
for what to secure their financial
future
for you youth oh well it's not it's not
very complicated uh
it goes back to
getting full use out of your own talents
first
i mean the difference between whether
you're going to be earning x or 2x or 3x
a year
20 years from now
[Music]
is going to be a function
of how well not how much talent you have
but how how well you use the talents you
already have
and
so that is
the your best financial future
is your own ability and and
and your
uh a capacity to
to use those abilities to their
potential
and
they can't take that can't be taken away
from you they can't even tax it
i mean uh you know most things if if you
on a you know a piece of real estate if
they double the taxes they double the
taxes and that changes your ownership in
the property because now in effect the
taxing authorities own more of it
because they've got a greater command on
the revenue stream uh the same thing
about
almost any asset you have uh
but
they they don't tax what's in your head
and they don't tax
your ability to
start performing when you when you get
to work in the morning and finish in the
evening uh to to your potential one of
the things that amazes me
is how people who really do perform well
just sort of jump out at you once you're
running a business when i got out of
school i thought you know everybody
would behave that way but they don't
most people sort of go
go through life in a sleepwalk and
and it if you don't
you will stand out so the big the
biggest thing for your financial future
is yourself well trust is the most
important thing as we discussed this a
few minutes ago
if people give me when i had no money
because when alibaba started
18 founders in my apartment
i told everybody say put your all your
money savings on the table
leaving
the money
for
10 months food
and room
you know rent what's that the money you
have put on the table i want to gather
the money and nobody should borrow the
money from parents nobody should borrow
money from friends because i don't want
to make your parents and friends
bankrupt because doing alibaba
so 18 people we gathered
50 000 u.s dollars we studied alibaba in
my apartment
and those people
actually none of us have money
but if if somebody say i give you 1
million u.s dollars
and i give you trust which one i would
choose i choose those people who give me
the trust because it's the trust that
make make
us
be united it's the truth i think 18
founders they trust me because they
trust
me i have to be very loyalty
to them
and loyal to the mission that
that we have
i think a lot of entrepreneurship know
that
i hate people work for me
i wanted people work for the mission
that we agreed together
because you don't want people work for
me because people like me when i look
when i look further this guy's a
handsome wayne get closer he's so ugly
everybody in the world the same
you should not get closer
further it's good so you think a jack is
great but you know if you get closer
not necessarily i'll be angry i will
happy i'm happy i got but
when people trusting you
that's the most valuable things
i think later when we got our event
venture capitalists invested us
the thing
they noticed is that because my team
trust me and i trust my teams so even
when it doesn't feel good
feedback can be a really really good
thing but first i want us to make a
distinction between feedback and
criticism because i think that's
important
feedback is the
energy or the return energy of what's
put out
this means that feedback is information
about or reactions to our state of being
and our performance and our our way of
being in relationship
feedback comes to us as a response or a
reaction or sometime as comments or a
review
of what we do and how we show up at any
given moment
feedback has a purpose the purpose of
feedback is to provide us with guidance
or direction that will
serve as the influence
for modification or change in our
behavior and in our energy so in other
words
feedback is a cue
that something we do or say or how we
behave needs to change that's all it is
now that sounds pretty harmless but but
here comes the challenge
most feedback either feels or sounds
critical
which means that it's going to trigger a
toxic memory or a feeling which then
motivates us to discount the feedback
we're receiving you know we we can't
even hear it
so so what is criticism then if if
feedback is criticism
what is criticism criticism is feedback
that demoralizes condemns judges or
blames
it's
feedback that is consciously or
unconsciously offered to manipulate or
control
that's the difference
where feedback is offered to motivate
correction or change criticism is
offered to manipulate and control and in
many many cases
while what
people offer
as constructive
criticism what they want to give us
it actually
criticizes us
and that's what leads to a mental or
emotional shutdown and we can lose the
value
of what's being offered because
criticism
is an offering now here's the good news
all criticism is feedback
and here's the bad news
all criticism is feedback
what i mean is this whether it's
positive or negative productive or
unproductive all feedback is telling you
something you need to know about
yourself and what you hear
and how you hear it has nothing to do
with who's saying it
all feedback is about who you be
and how you be
and it's bringing that to your awareness
there's something you need to change
beloved
whether it is coming at you from your
mother or your sister or your boss or
your coworker or your partner
feedback is a source of information for
self-improvement i want to share a
little story about the ship of theseus
which is this ancient greek parable
story about this ship that goes into
athens greece and parks in the dock
and as it's there
it's used year after year some of the
boards start to wear away some of them
start to go bad and so whenever one
board is bad they take the board out and
change it and put a new one in this
process continues for 25 or 30 years
until every board that is on the ship
has been changed out for a new one
and philosophers for centuries have
asked is this the same boat is this the
same thing that was there before is both
entirely the same and entirely new
and i would say that your habits can be
the same way we often fear that in order
to achieve something new to become
someone new we have to abandon
everything that we are but in fact
that's not how it works change can
happen plank by plank board by board
habit by habit and gradually you can
become someone new with consistency and
repetition you can actually change not
only your results but actually your
identity
and the reason that this is true is
because the more evidence that we have
for a belief the more likely we are to
believe it
so
if you go to church every sunday for 20
years you believe that you are religious
if you study spanish every thursday
night for 20 minutes you believe that
you are studious the actions that you
take provide evidence for who you are
and it's not that
habits matter more necessarily on an
individual basis each moment in life
matters but what ends up happening is
that over the broad span of time things
that you do once or twice fade away and
things that you do time after time day
after day week after week accumulate the
bulk of the evidence for what you
believe about yourself
and so every action that you take is
actually a vote for the type of person
that you want to become
if you want to become someone new
then you can take a new action and begin
to accumulate evidence for that identity
for that belief about yourself
and that the more votes that you cast
the more likely you are to win the
election you don't need to be unanimous
you don't have to be perfect all the
time you just need to have the body of
work right
so true change is actually not behavior
change it's not results change it's not
process change it's identity change the
goal is not to become the goal is not to
read a book it's to become a reader the
goal is not to write a book or write an
article to become a writer the goal is
not to run a marathon to become a runner
to become a type of person to develop an
identity
and the way to being something or
becoming someone is through doing
something so every time you sit down to
write every time you practice that habit
you are being a writer every time you
play a sport you're being an athlete
every time you practice painting or
music or whatever you're being an artist
your identity emerges out of the habits
that you have
and so
here's the secret to this talk
it's not just about getting you to make
small changes it's not just about
putting a book on your pillow or putting
an apple on the counter it's actually
about getting you to believe something
new about yourself something possible
about yourself
and habits are not only the method
through which we achieve external
measures of success like losing weight
or gaining more earning more money or
meditating and reducing stress they are
also the path through which we achieve
internal change and actually become
someone new they're the path through
which we forge the identity that we have
the deepest beliefs we have about
ourselves our sense of self and so if
you 20 year old or 25 year old self was
sitting right here where i'm at
and you could sit down and have a
conversation with him what would you
want to say to him you know he used to
prepare on developing what makes him
happy
in life
let's drive on um
developing that and cultivating that
what makes you happy
and that strong alliance within yourself
and what makes you happy and never break
that
because that's all of uh
really true we will get a hundred
million now we've been moving what is
happening
what is the essence of happening what
does that mean
everybody has a different definition
where we've got seven million people i'm
sure seven million different definitions
you know some people may have dark
happiness they like to do dark stuff and
that makes them happy
but it's still happy
so what makes necessary happy a good
thing
what makes you happy
simple stuff and i don't know if that's
happy i take it for granted sometimes
like everyone else is my kid yeah yeah
and i have to you know not worried about
going to prison i'm worried about paying
my bills and having my lights on and my
life being cut off with my water being
cut off yeah
it's being stable in my life
yeah
she would tell him to start pursuing
happiness more
you know that's the word that we use you
know but that's the only thing that's
going to stimulate us
yeah you know
with drugs i don't know this happiness
we call it happiness sure why is it the
word happiness that makes us think this
is something that we should no mean
[ __ ] ascend to yeah why happiness
because
yeah we look at the response of
happiness what it looks like yeah we
should always
ascend happiness visualization is
a gift to your heart and your soul it's
a gift because if the the idea
is the seed
visualization
is the is the um it's the fertilizer
it's the fertilizer because when your
thoughts are connected with an emotion
see you would visualize yourself winning
and you would feel all the emotion that
came with that and all you're doing now
is you're not chasing a foreign emotion
you know the feeling and now you're just
doing what's necessary to get back to
that feeling in real time exactly and so
what what a good friend of mine vishen
um of the ceo of mindvalley who you know
um i would i did a visualization with
him we were in bali
and
um he said to me afterwards i never get
emotional
he does it he doesn't get emotional he's
like right right yeah well
he was like i cried but i got emotional
he goes i figured it out it's
visualization
a good visualization brings an emotion
he was like that's how you do it and so
um i i love doing visualizations because
and it's really important in the
visualization you can't see it over
there you have to see it right here feel
it you gotta feel it right here like i
am it's all i am i am i am in my dream
home i am in my dream relationship and
then unpack what that looks like but
most importantly unpack what it feels
like and when you have that that emotion
in this moment all of a sudden you stir
up something that i don't think will
ever go back to sleep it'll go okay
let's go get that and what it really
does is it sets up a state of cognitive
dissonance
and cognitive dissonance is when you see
something in your mind and you see
yourself in a way that your behaviors
are not currently leading to and so your
mind becomes disrupted and it goes okay
can we get there right because i'm not
there right now not there right now and
that's not comfortable your mind wants
to literally be congruent what it thinks
is what you're doing what it thinks is
what you're doing and so when you set up
a constant and abundant thinkers like
you and i we do it unconsciously we cut
we're constantly keeping ourselves in a
state of cognitive dissonance meaning
okay what else and i'm seeing lisa over
there and i'm going okay let me go wow
while being grateful for my now yeah
it's not in that i'm going to be whole
and complete when i get over there i'm
holding complete now
i just know i'm supposed to be over
there so let me do what's necessary to
get over there and let me let me evict
any behaviors or characteristics that
are stopping me and let me adopt any new
ones that i need four years ago
i got in a really big
fight i started getting angrier and
angrier in my life as i was achieving
more and more financially
accomplishments awards all the things
the nice things that you mentioned in
the beginning as those were happening
i would find myself more and more
triggered emotionally
from
simple attacks that people had on me
whether it be like online on social
media or in person
in my relationship i was very triggered
where
i would just get more and more bent out
of shape and hurt in certain situations
and frustrated resentful
and one day at the i was playing a lot
of pickup basketball at this time and so
over six month period i was playing a
lot of pickup basketball
and i was literally every time i would
go i would get in some type of
altercation usually these extreme verbal
altercations screaming
if anyone ever
stepped to me on the pickup courts in
the rough west hollywood uh neighborhood
mean street the main streets of west
hollywood you know if anyone stepped to
me
um it was like an instant
alpha
reaction of like territory like i own
this this is my court
don't ever try to talk to me in a bad
way don't try to foul me in the wrong
way
and let alone i was doing the same thing
to them so i was like right um but for
whatever reason all these things started
coming up more and more and i was
getting more and more aggressive at the
basketball courts
in relationships and then i would take
it out on the courts
on like 18 year old kids you know these
kids weren't even that big right
um and one day there was a guy who was
actually bigger than me uh and older
than me and we were going at it like you
know two silverback gorillas like try to
just like get their land you know what i
mean
um
and it got down to a really heated
moment where he headbutted me and it was
just like
years of built up tension came out in
that moment where i you know like
superhuman strength came upon me it was
just like rage and anger
i had zero control zero control over my
emotions i allowed my ego
my masks to own me as opposed to having
emotional intelligence and owning the
moment
[Music]
and um we got a pretty bad fight and at
the end of it i was just so fired up i
couldn't believe what i did and
the guy's face was just mauled bleeding
everywhere and i was just like what did
i just do
what am i what am i doing it was just
like i remember running home in shame
and fear
one because the
the police station is right across the
street from these mean streets of west
hollywood and um i was just like what am
i doing like i have everything to lose
in this moment
what's why am i allowing myself to be so
frustrated so angry to fight this guy on
a simple basketball game where there's
zero stakes
no one's watching there's no money at
stake
it's just my ego at stake
and i remember going home looking in the
mirror and just being like who are you
louis like who are you but i was
trembling i was trembling i was like
what are you doing and who are you
and that was the moment where i was like
i almost needed that catalyst to be like
okay it's time to reevaluate everything
every relationship
my my the intimate relationship i was in
at the time relationship with my family
friends everything and the most
important relationship
which was i really believe most people
are terrified of
embarrassment they might call it
something else
but they're
scared of embarrassment i just put this
video out where it starts for the first
line is you're not scared to start your
dream
you're embarrassed to be seen starting
small
and it just blew up on social media for
us i think i got more
direct messages on that one little post
than anything i've ever done and uh
people really resonated with it
and because if you think about the truth
about it is that's what it is for a lot
of people they don't
if they quit their job and they go to
start something new they don't want all
their former you know people to see them
doing something that looks the you know
new and fresh and and maybe ugly or not
put together they're scared to be
embarrassed and have other people judge
them
they're scared they might use different
language well you know
you know they might say well i'm just
fearful but if you really dig down the
fearful most people are just scared to
be embarrassed they're scared to try
something and obviously fail at it
and the perception of that failure
really shuts them down
so
we have to ask different questions and i
ask this all the time i literally use
the word embarrassment i said listen i
i'll say something like
are you not going to try this before we
even get to this like you can see it you
made it happen are you not going to try
it because you're scared of what
somebody else might think
are you not going to try it because
you're scared of somebody of what
somebody else might think
i ask that all the time
and
almost all the time
people go
well you know
i'm not scared but uh you know i'm
worried what my spouse will think i'm
not scared but yeah you know the people
at work might think i'm a little crazy
and i'll explore that with them because
if we can't get them
over that line of embarrassment and the
willingness
for trial and error
we won't get them to do anything
and so my way through embarrassment
for for me
is two different ways just depending on
who the person is when i hear that
someone might be embarrassed to do
something
um i'll often start with that past
attempt conversation have you tried
something like this before and people
were horrible to you
and they're always like well no i've
never tried this before oh so you're
making an assumption
that you'd feel uncomfortable
but then i also want to give them
permission of like
is this dream worth having a few people
think you're crazy
is this dream worth having a few people
think you're crazy
and i'll open up that dialogue well yeah
okay well who might think you're crazy
well my spouse is going to think i'm
crazy cool how are they going to
communicate that to you well they're
going to call me stupid have they ever
called you stupid before well no or yes
they have i say okay so you you survived
it last time they called you stupid
would it be worth surviving it again if
they call you stupid if you felt better
because you actually got momentum
towards something that matters to you
like oh
yeah and listen
knowing
that a big frame here and helping people
get over excuses is getting them tied
back to
is what they are after important
i brought that up earlier how important
is this to you do you really want this
well if you said that's important isn't
it worth a little discomfort
haven't you been discomforted before
haven't you
felt judged and stupid before okay so
you know you'll survive that now the
question is so the question is about
survival right let's say yeah it's not
about survivors great question is about
survival
sounds to me
like the real question
is whether you want it
we know you'll survive
i'm curious
what if we know you'll survive
what will it feel like if you're
thriving
would it be worthwhile to have a few
doubters
or look stupid
or be seen as silly
if you woke up
energized by what you were doing
would that be worth it
[Music]
if you want to know how to transform
your entire world with a few simple
habits check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there come to learn to come to be a
better version of yourself too many
people start off trying to prove
that they are worthy of being there
trying to prove that they should be in
charge